à 16h le laboratoire ferme ses portes
pour accueillir les personnes présentant
des symptômes évocateurs du coc vide 19
et ainsi éviter le contact avec la
patiente est l'habituel ces personnes
peuvent bénéficier d'un dépistage par
test pcr par voie nasale
le test est assez rapide en soi puisque
certains prélèvements dans les deux
narines on introduit un écouvillon à ses
fins jusqu'au nasopharynx donc ça va
assez loin
et voilà donc le test dure quelques
minutes un chaque jour une vingtaine de
personnes est testé dans ce laboratoire
de retour d'un séjour à l'étranger cette
patiente souffre d'une dégradation de
son état respiratoire
j'ai fait un voyage en république
dominicaine au mois de mars et les
premiers signes de va dire de tout son
arrivée à mon retour pour effectuer le
dépistage du coronavirus il ne faut en
aucun cas se rendre directement dans le
laboratoire de biologie
le rendez vous se prend au préalable par
email afin d'éviter et tous documents
susceptibles d'être contaminés le virus
peut donner une palette de symptômes
très variés les enveloppes sont pas
vraiment reconnue comme un symptôme
courant mais c'est les personnes jeunes
c'était pas mal observé par les dermatos
même si c'est pas garantie à côté de ça
c'est un peu de mal de tête un peu de
température les personnes identifiées
comme cas contacts peuvent également se
faire dépister c'est le cas de cette
mère de famille
fièvre vomissements courbatures je vais
faire un prénom dans les eaux tareen le
test est facile à effectuer non invasif
mais désagréable pour le patient car un
peu douloureux
les résultats sont communiqués dans les
24 heures en attendant le médecin
préconise de rester à son domicile